so here
we have our solar systems. Now. How would we solve this?
again to solve a system
is to have
an upper triangle
an upper triangle looks like this.
This is the upper trying right? This is the
other triangle.
You have a leading zeros.
Under their main or what we call the principal diagonal.
So every number to the right or above the principal
diagonal is a non-zero value.
and everything obviously below that
is a
is a zero.
So this is called Echelon 4 this whole
Matrix, but that is called the upper. This is the
upper triangle.
now
to solve for the roots of
the inequalities
the numbers
of the upper triangle most also be once
So this would be one one one and you
know, everything else that we would be zero.
Okay, so for Led composition, we don't need to make
these ones.
But when we do gaussian elimination, we do what these to
be once. Anyway, what I'm trying to say is that this is upper triangle.
Okay, so we need to get our inequality our
system rather in Upper triangular form and then
get these.
What why do we just also called pivots the numbers across
the principal diagonal
called pivots? We need to make these pivots equal to one.
So let me show you and of course. This is a
this is reduced. Well reduce row
Echelon form. So once we get the pivots across
the diagonal equal to one we have then achieved reduced row
Echelon form.
I'm going to keep this picture as reference.
so
Okay.
one one
so, let's see how we can do this equation. So I'm going to
copy it again.
And paste it.